la finalité d'université 133 c'est de
puiser dans l'histoire du centre afin
d'affiner le regard centriste sur les
grands enjeux contemporains et de voir
comment sur un temps long on peut
aujourd'hui dans cette période de doute
et d'incertitude formuler des
propositions politiques cohérentes et
forte pour l'avenir de s'interroger
aussi sur la culture politique centriste
le modem à la place historique je dirais
centrale dans le cadre du centrisme
puisque encore une fois la légitimité il
la tire de son histoire la culture
politique du centre aujourd'hui n'a pas
de raison d'être figée sur son passé
même si il s'enrichit de se passer au
contraire al'approche où la
confrontation de ces grands enjeux
cette culture politique s'élargit se
développe mais encore une fois elle
reste marquée et fortifiés par le
fondement historique qui est le sien
libéraux du 19e ont posé défini des
lignes de force qui se retrouve à
l'identique dans le mouvement démocrate
aujourd'hui la l'esprit pluralisme le
goût de la délibération le dépassement
des clivages la recherche de la justice
sociale la combinaison de défense de la
liberté et souci de légalité le centre
se distingue des autres mouvements
politiques par une culture qui a
toujours été une forme d'indépendance
dans les votes qui l'a émis certes le
centre a connu un certain nombre
d'alliances politiques desquelles il
restait aussi dépendants mais in fine et
le vote sur tel ou tel grand projet
restait caractérisé par une forme
d'autonomie donc je dirais que d'abord
il est un parti une force autonome
deuxièmement le centre par rapport aux
autres structures politiques à une
approche qui restent largement non
dogmatique précisément parce que la
culture politique qui a été la sienne
lui a permis de construire en
positionnement tout au long des
décennies passées
et puis peut-être une troisième marque
de la singularité du centre celle
tempérament 1 le centre je dirais
presque vie de la diversité des
personnes qui le composent
on peut le voir sur un certain nombre de
projets de loi qui aujourd'hui ou de
propositions de lois qui sont adoptées
au parlement
il n'y a pas forcément une homogénéité
exclusive des élus du groupe a voté dans
le même sens et je pense que s'il ya une
cohérence d'ensemble
il y a aussi une diversité qui le fait
vivre et ça c'est l'essentiel je pense
dans une démocratie moderne